مرحبا انا في تباسيل لنتابع معا ابرز
اخبار الاسبوع الماضي بايجاز وضمن ابرز
الاحداث جيش الاحتلال ينفذ عمليه واسعه في
جنين رئيس فاجنر في روسيا وميتا تطلق منصه
واخبار اخرى لنتابعها معا
نبدا نشرتنا من فلسطين التي شهدت صعيدا
غير مسبوقها بعد اقتحام قوات الاحتلال
مخيم جنين للمره الاولى منذ عشرين عاما
باكثر من ثلاثه الاف جندي ومئتي الي
عسكريه وعشرات الطائرات الاحتلال انسحب من
المدينه ومخيمها تحت نيران المقاومه مخلفا
اثني عشر شهيدا ونحن 120 جريحا ودمارا
هائلا في المنازل والبنى التحتيه تزامنا
مع الاقتحام اصيب سبعه مستوطنين في عمليه
دهس وطعن في تل ابيب واعتبرتها الفصائل
ردا اوليا على اقتحام مخيم جنين بينما قتل
جندي اسرائيلي في عمليه اطلاق نار قربه
مستوطنه
غربي نابلس العمليتان تبنتهما حركه حماس
ينضم الينا خليل شاهين مدير البحث في
المركز الفلسطيني للدراسات والبحوث
الاستراتيجيه سيد خليل ما الذي اراده
الاحتلال من اقتحام مخيم جنين
الهدف الرئيسي الاستراتيجي للعدوان على
مخيم جنين كان اجتثاف حاله المقاومه
برمتها في مخيم جنين ومن ثم في مدينه جنين
وربما ايضا في القرى التابعه لها ولذلك
كانت هناك عناوين فرعيه الطابع استراتيجي
ايضا تحت هذا العنوان العريض اولها
استعاده الردع للجيش الاسرائيلي وثانيها
ضمان قضيه حركه قوات الاحتلال لدى اقتحام
مجانين دون مقاومه فلسطينيه والثالث هو
وقف ايه هجمات على الطرقات وعلى
المستوطنات بمعنى توفير بيئه مستقره
لتوسيع الاستيطان في شمال الضفه الغربيه
كل هذه الاهداف فشلت شكرا سيد خليل الان
الى تطورات وردود الافعال المتواصله على
حادثه حرق نسخه من المصحف الشريف في
السويد فقد طالبت العراق السويد بتسليم
المنفذ ذيل اصول العراقيه لمحاكمته في حين
تظاهر الاف في باكستان وفي دول عده تمديدا
نسخه من المصحف الشريف بالسويداء بينما
نددت السلطات التركيه بالحادثه واكدت ان
انقره لن تخضع للضغوطات من اجل دعم انضمام
السويد الى حلف الناتو ومجلس حقوق الانسان
التابع للامم المتحده يقول انه سيعقد جلسه
طارئه لمناقشه الحادثه رواد المنصات
تفاعلوا بشده على واقع هذه التطورات لنقرا
بعض التعليقات نبدا مع محمد محمد يقول
حرقوا نسخه من المصحف عمل مشين واستفزازي
لمشاعر المسلمين والرد العملي على ذلك
تدشين مشروع مليوني حافظ للقران الكريم
الله تكفل بحفظه نضال يقول حرق نسخه من
المصحف ولا ردود على مر الايام الا جعجعات
زاد من الاستهانه بامه المليار حتى استكلب
هؤلاء فلا رد لهم الا بدرس يعلمهم ان
الاسلام له رجال اقوال افعال ولا يرضون
ايهاان دستورهما من السويد الى بيلاروسيا
اذا قال الرئيس البيلاروسي ان مقاتلي
فاجنر ليسوا في بلاده وانا رئيس المجموعه
موجود في روسيا واضاف انه عرض على مجموعه
فاغنر الاقامه في قواعد عسكريه سابقه كانت
تستخدم في العهد السوفيتي في اراضي
بيلاروسيا مؤكدا ان نظيره الروسي لا ينوي
القضاء على المجموعه في المقابل اعلن
الكريم عدم مراقبه تحركات بريكوجين واشار
الى ان الاتفاق مع فاجنر لا يزال قائما
الجزيره قامت برصد مواقع يعتقد ان قوات
فاجنر ستتمركز فيها يمكنكم متابعه الصور
في التعليقات الى امريكا وصراع بين قطبين
نشاط التواصل ميته وتويتر حيث اطلقت شركه
ميتا منصتها الجديده ثريتس في مسعد
لمنافسه منصه تويتر وتجاوز عدد مستخدمي
المنصه 50 مليونا بعد 24 ساعه من جاء
توقيت اعلان التطبيق الجديد في وقت شهدت
فيه منصه تويتر تحديثات وتقييدات اثارت
السياقه عدد من المستخدمين بعد شرائها من
قبل ايلون ماسكار في المقابل هددت شركه
تويتر بمقادات شركه ميتا بسبب منصتها
الجديده
وذلك في خطاب ارسله محامي تويتر الى مارك
زوكربيرج الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه الام
لموقع فيسبوك لكن كيف سيكون تاثير منصه
على منصه التويتر نسال حول هذا الموضوع
محمد السويسي الصحفي المختص في شؤونه
الاتصال اهلا سيد محمد هل تشكل منصه
تهديدا وجوديا على منصه تويتر اظن ان
المهدد الاساسي بالنسبه لتويتر ستكون
سيكون تويتر هو نفسه استراتيجيه
لتطوير الشركه وتطوير المنصه في المستقبل
كل ما قام به
اشهر الماضيه لا يصب في مصلحه تويتر اما
بالنسبه
فالمنصه الجديده تعتمد على انستغرام
ومستعملي انستقرام هم مستعملون مغيرون
لمستعملي تويتر انستقرام يعتمد على محتوى
شبابي محتوى مقاطع فيديو قصيره ستوريات
ويلز وصور لكن بالنسبه لتويتر يعتمد على
شريحه مثقفه شريحه
تبحث عن التاثير التاثير سيكون غائب على
المستقبل لكن نسبه الاستعمال ستكون اكبر
نظرا لقوه منصه انستقرام واهميتها بالنسبه
لمنصه لشركه شكرا سيد محمد ننهي نشرتنا
هذا الاسبوع بابرز الاخبار الرياضيه اذا
اطلقت حكومه توريو ديجينيرو بالبرازيل
اسمها مهاجم ريال مدريد فينيسيوس جونيور
على قانون لمناهضه العنصريه والتي ينص على
ايقاف او الغاء منافسات رياضيه في حال
حدوث تصرف عنصري واوضحت وسائل برازيليه ان
القانون مستلهم من واقعه فينيسيوس في ملعب
مستايا حين توقفت المباراه وعدت دقائق
عندما واجه اللاعب المشجعين الذين اهنوه
في المدرجات وفي اخبارنا الرياضيات الاخرى
يحدثنا الزميل لؤي محمود مذيع النشره
الرياضيه عن ابرز صفقات الانتقالات التي
تمت والمتوقعه ايضا بالنسبه لمتابعي الكره
العربيه هو انضمام البرازيلي روبرتو
فيرمينو الى فريق الاهلي السعودي قادما من
ليفربول الانجليزي بعد نهايه عقده الخبر
المهم ان الروبيرتو ينضم الى مجموعه كبيره
من النجوم الذين قدموا الى الدوري السعودي
بتاثير الفراشه او تاثير انضمام البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو الاخبار ايضا هذا
الاسبوع هو الاعلان رسميا عن تولي لويس
انريكي تدريب باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي
هذا الخبر مهم لماذا لان الوسنريكي مدرب
مشهود له بالكفاءه وبالقدره على بناء جيل
جديد وهو ما يحتاج اليه باريس سان جيرمان
في السنوات المقبله ربما الخبر الابرز
شخصيا هو فوز ريال مدريد على برشلونه في
موضوع الصفقات ريال مدريد لم يفوز بالدوري
لم يفوز بدوري ابطال اوروبا ولكنه فاز على
برشلونه بالضربه القاضيه في صفقه انتقال
اللاعب التركي اردوير الذي يوصف بانه ميسي
تركيا او الموهبه الشابه الجديده في الكره
الاوروبيه التقارير ربط بينه وبين برشلونه
لكنه في نهايه المطاف اختار الانتقال الى
ريال مدريد يوجه ريال مدريد ضربه قويه الى
برشلونه في حرب الانتقاليه فلماذا شخصيا
باختصار برشلونه
بهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه النشره
الاجازه الاسبوعين ننتظره الاسبوع المقبل
شكرا على حسن المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]